[Music]
what exactly is mom's new job she's an
advocate for superheroes but I thought
superheroes were still illegal so things
haven't spiraled out of control the
moment I left looks normal to me I'll be
there
hey little baby PG did you wash your
hands with soap did you dry them all
vegetables all vegetable I did so are we
going to talk about it what the elephant
in the room weren't elephants mom's new
job
it's time to make some wrong things
right hell they bring supers back into
the sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I'll watch the kids no problem
not the way you're supposed to do it dad
they wants to do it Nigel no that way
why would they change math masses math
yes hello hey honey
everything's great
[Music]
he's in excellent health is freaky you
know it's crazy right to help my family
I gotta leave it to fix the law I gotta
break it you got to destroy kids can
have that choice thank you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen slider interrupts this
program for important announced that it
might get weird I'll be there
[Music]